my name is will and as far as I can
remember I've always dreamt of having an
afro no one had ever thought of putting
afros together with civil rights in town
and the police got so poppin that even
white folks would come here to get their
hair done
that's Marvin he the barber from across
the street and the guys he's sitting
with his brothers happy the big is and
kinda anaconda don't ask the Vixen with
the multicolored nails that's Karen
Marvin's girlfriend
the Portrait Gallery wouldn't be
completed I didn't tell you about no but
her brother is a bit jealous so I try to
keep that affair confidential you see my
foot I saw hanging one of those people
delivery boys again which one I
respected good well put a multi-car I
said look like you ground me for him you
study cook me in my dorm one town Amanda
comes out she sees me she's convinced
they might kick by some jealous husband
whose wife I'm paying she's my kid back
specifically I want you to find him
right now no existe better kiss please
I didn't I think was the one I don't
want that did it based on your head I
will teach you it's not part of the plan
[Music]
shut up girl what's wrong with you yeah
you even though you deal with that your
reads face you'll notice disciple
raisins or on ronamoon not a dish I
reckon you sir
no like obi-wan I trusted you I mean
winning would suck it's a little
stomachache and we mean in a driver one
step out of the door before nice Lavinia
double role should be pissed off make
his triple body of any minute come on of
a team are waiving sovereign wonderful
for the burger mouth full no trouble
close your mouth they go crazy Rick they
don't stop he'll stop it did in the end
of each they saw each other you won't be
the next dish when they mean you you
want this in a bloodbath huh no I was
psyched about my piranha story because
the girls were so freaked out they
didn't say a word when I told them bring
back his wife immediately Oh
everything's gonna be fine though the
following days stormy winds through
across New Orleans temperatures
increased and Denzel sank into a sharp
paranoia
Oh have you seen notes about woody
where's woody if he's in his room ding
wait wait weeks no let's go
wake up dammit what my sister's missing
what
no didn't come home last night did she
say anything what about will
what about will this place is closing in
and home there you go
they're probably together they've got
nothing to do together
can you get a net you ha
you